[Musique]
Madison est en BTS production animale au
lycée de tour Fondettes c'est sa
deuxième participation à ce concours des
Olympiades comme j'ai un projet
d'installation
voilà ce qui est connaissance l'état de
santé des brebis et comment conduire son
troupeau c'est très important et tout ce
qui est à prendre et bon à prendre ils
sont 36 de toute la région à concourir
sur différentes épreuves théoriques et
pratiques santé génétique engraissement
manipulation tous les gestes du
quotidien d'un éleveur c'est une sorte
de TP supplémentaire en fait dans des
conditions un peu concours on se
challenge ensemble ils peuvent ils
débrief tout le temps sur les épreuves
d'ailleurs entre chaque épreuve c'est
hyper intéressant et c'est vrai que
souvent on a des jeunes qui n'ont pas de
d'atelier au vin sur leur exploitation
agricole
on appuie sur la sécurité pour faire
venir vers nous l'animal et d'un coup
sec et ferme on la retourne des brebis
qui ont besoin par exemple d'une
manucure ça s'appelle le parage des
onglons et sa demande une certaine
dextérité le but c'est vraiment
de la ligne blanche et en fait quand on
a toujours peur d'aller trop loin et de
la faire signer parce que ça c'est une
super vite et on a toujours peur du coup
bah on y va on n'ose pas et au final bah
faudrait oser mais bon dans le jury des
techniciens des enseignants mais aussi
des professionnels soucieux du
renouvellement de la profession
juste à la limite beaucoup
d'arriculteurs ont plus de 55 ans ils
vont partir et de voir des jeunes venir
s'intéresser à part et des moutons
l'étrier les tripoter sentir un peu le
mouton rentre en soi bah c'est agréable
parce que ça se dit que on est la
filière est quand même pas complètement
foutue dans la région le cheptel est en
croissance mais pas suffisant la moitié
de la consommation de viande en France
est importée et la filière estime à
10000 en tout le nombre d'emplois a pour
voir les deux finalistes l'ont bien
compris
chaque semaine on était là à faire une
heure de cours et puis les TP mercredi
après-midi on y allait vraiment jusqu'à
hier soir ensemble on a révisé encore
pour ce concours enfin on n'est pas venu
ici pour on est venu pour la gagne et
David a terminé 5e sur 40 à la finale
nationale une très belle mention
supplémentaire sur son CV